[Music]
in the previous part of the video we've
seen that hydrogen and oxygen react to
form water let's talk about another
chemical equation zinc reacts with
sulfuric acid to give us zinc sulfate
and hydrogen do you notice something
interesting about these two equations
okay
let's draw a table under the first
equation in the first column we write
the symbol of the elements that are
involved in the equation then in the
second column we write the number of
atoms in the reactants and in the third
we write the number of atoms in the
products which are the elements involved
in the first equation just two elements
so we write H and O in the first column
now for each of these elements we need
to find the number of atoms on the
reactant side the number of atoms of
hydrogen is 2 and the number of atoms of
oxygen is also 2 now we move to the
right-hand side which has the product
how many atoms of hydrogen exists in the
product - that's right and how many
atoms of oxygen just one for each
element we look at the numbers written
in the second and the third column for
hydrogen we see that the number of atoms
on each side is equal but for oxygen we
see that the number of atoms on the left
is 2 and that on the right is just 1 do
you know what we call such an equation
yes unbalanced equation if the number of
atoms of each element on the reactant
side is not equal to the number of atoms
of the respective elements on the
product side then we say that the
equation is unbalanced now can you make
a similar table for the equation on the
right can you fill in the values in
these cells
okay so did you make a list of the
elements present in this equation we
have zinc hydrogen sulfur and oxygen on
the Left the number of atoms of zinc is
1 and that on the right is also 1 and
similarly we find out the remaining
cells of these three elements what do
you observe you notice that for each
element the number of atoms on the
reactant side is equal to the number of
atoms on the product side and note my
words it's true for each of the elements
involved in the equation we call such a
chemical equation a balanced equation
now you know the difference between
Palast and unbalanced chemical equations
but why is the unbalanced equation
called so do you remember the law of
conservation of mass according to the
law of conservation of mass mass can
neither be created nor destroyed in a
chemical reaction so the total mass of
elements present in the reactants must
be equal to the total mass of elements
in the products in laymen terms the
number of atoms of each element must be
the same before and after the chemical
reaction hence we say that the first
chemical equation is unbalanced can we
balance this equation though yes we
can't balance an unbalanced chemical
equation how can we do that we will see
that next
[Music]
you